we do have a really crazy story that I
saw and I almost just don't believe it
suspected SARS virus and flu samples
found in luggage FBI report describes
China's viral bio risk biosecurity risk
notices crazy
yeah but the craziest thing about it is
that they they buried the lede so this
story really yes so this story from
Yahoo they're like the if luggage they
found some some virus samples and when I
first saw this I was like wow that seems
crazy like what somebody had viruses in
their bags why would they do that yeah
and then halfway down the article there
like researchers believe it was for
bioterrorism things like what what yeah
what whoa whoa whoa well when you first
brought this up I was like oh yeah right
about that wasn't that like two years
ago and and like no that was six months
ago
it's way crazier six months ago
apparently at ember September of 2019 a
Chinese biologist and it's happened
multiple times did not report so there's
numerous instances now where Chinese
biologists I guess they're calling a
biologist won't even know they're
biologists terrorists no no no really
that we don't know we don't know
they suspect yeah it could be used for
nefarious purposes but these Chinese
individuals they're saying biologists
okay fine had multiple vials of viruses
yeah in their luggage undeclared and
denied having anything until they were
searched and then in the in the main
story they bring up this is totally
burying the lede
so they say in this story that was like
in November of 2018 the Loblaw it's like
dude wait wait wait wait this happened
in September again it keeps happening
why would they why would young who lead
with the November store this is terrible
reporting agreed because there's so much
more important information here but at
least they did it they got the expert
the expert said we think this so
basically ah who's the one who clarifies
the this expert who said it's a
biosecurity risk they said biosecurity
is a reference to the nefarious use of
biological agents such as bioterrorism
how disaster everywhere I don't have
that know it's from yesterday what
really scares me is this is the there's
one guy that got caught right that's it
that's what we know about even this
woman says you realize if somebody was
sneaking the stuff in you know people
sneaking stuff out right yeah both ways
dude look at this photo see these things
that's it they put little vials in
plastic baggies and those are what your
contact lens cases you ever CEOs it's
just in a contact lens case no they're
like many miles those are the top of the
vial oh oh I see okay so I'm hoping they
were in like you know yeah what I'm
trying to think of a movie what's the
movie where I can't remember it I think
it's fast in the fears or something okay
where like it's every action movie they
have a case and you open it and then
there's like foam padding yeah padding
and then they pull out a tube and they
unscrew the tube and they pull out
another two but then they try to top up
and pull out tiny vial yeah like it's
secured in numerous things right like
it's almost with a battery system
keeping it under sir right but you're
exactly and it's like here's real life
they're like look at these little vials
that are in plastic baggies in this bag
and it says I picture a guy with the
long overcoat and he opens it up like
what kind of the virus you want I got
this one I got this one this one's
really good I don't I'm surprised this
story I can't believe it's real I gotta
be honest I can't believe it's really
there because because no one else is
touching it why one says they're scare I
think they're scared because who wants
to be the person to come out and accuse
China of engaging in covert bioterror
well they started it well I mean sure
but the issue is you have to accuse this
person of doing it and another thing to
bring up in the article is that anybody
who was smelling the stuff in would be a
stooge and like you were saying the
piracy thing like we don't we didn't
condone this his action here's the
here's what they'll do they'll find some
poor guy in China you know like a poor
person
yes sir and they'll be like hey we need
you to bring my wife's clothes to her
and you know Detroit or whatever and
they'll be like okay great and I'll be
like here it is it'll open up and show
them like yeah you've got your your
contact lenses and you've got your
clothes just go to Detroit but don't
don't put those contacts on them don't
use those contacts by the way so
apparently but I think the FBI let these
guys go and they know who it is
and they even said that it says that
when it was first stopped that one of
the first stories not even the first
time it's happened in November 2018 that
they had vials label labeled antibodies
and then the biologist told the agents
that a colleague in China had asked him
to deliver the vials to a researcher
at a US Institute after examining the
vials however customs agents came to an
alarming conclusion so wait he even
admits that he was smuggling it for
someone else yeah like someone asked me
to do it it's like with no no capacity
that asked a colleague and asked me to
do it there patsies yeah dude they're
smuggling in viruses yeah that's crazy
and now look I'm the last person that's
what ever wanted wanting to engage in
any kind of conspiracy theory but this
is an FBI report that Chinese guy was
carrying the virus with pictures of it
and then said straight up someone asked
him to deliver it and then an expert
said like I don't look man I don't know
how you get more definitive than that I
know that's straight from the usb
artists injustice is straight up saying
that we knew that they were smuggling in
these viruses and now sure enough
there's a pandemic going around yep so
you know what it could be I mean it
could be that they're fiddling around
and it's this crazy man you know I can't
stand about the media's journalists are
supposed to be to a certain degree a
conspiracy theorist right you're
supposed to say hey I see something I
don't investigate it yeah exactly today
if you say isn't it strange that there's
a bio weapon there's a bio lab I don't
know about there's a bio lab in Wuhan
and that's where the virus originated
that's that's interesting right yeah
let's let's take a look at it the moment
you say that the media is like and they
start screeching conspiracy theories
yeah like dude Donald Trump could said
that how are these masks going missing
something must be going on and then all
of a sudden they're calling them a
conspiracy theorists yeah that's that's
how you these people they have no
imagination they are horrible at their
jobs and even these guys and I'll get
I'll give some credit to the journalists
who worked on this one they bury the
lead and I'm this has got to be fake
right maybe that I think that's another
issue
maybe the reason no one's touching it is
because they're like there's no way this
is real optimism bias nobody wants to
put their name on a story this crazy
I mean when I see I mean sure this
document right here the US Department of
Justice can you pull up the things that
see what I'm talking about so it says
like the US Department of Justice this
looks like a legitimate file from like
our government that
it got it in here the information
pictures yeah this is in nude look at
this right easy so they know about this
look at this on 1111 September 2019 a
Chinese national initially made no
positive declarations but was later
found to have eight vials of a clear
liquid in their checked luggage at the
Detroit metropolitan Wayne County
Airport the vials had no supporting
documentation the Chinese national state
of the material was DNA derived from it
low pathogenicity strain of h9 and two
however some of the vials had WS and
hand right on the top and through open
source research CBP determined wsn is an
acronym associated with the h1n1
influenza collected in 1933 the material
was confiscated and the individual was
allowed to travel to Dallas where they
were traveling to work with a researcher
associated with an identified US
research institution so in that instance
it seems like they might know who these
people are yeah and that because they
have cover from American institutions at
least in that regard maybe that's why
they didn't lead with that one right
because maybe it seems that their story
that they're going to meet with a
researcher that this is for them you
know whether or not they had official
documentation you know their story kind
of checked out like oh they are going to
meet with this person who is legitimate
source whatever but there was there
there have been numerous arrests of
researchers taking Chinese money and not
disclosing it yeah at schools at
reputable schools colleges and
universities well
that illustration man and how is that
not included in this you know how is
that not this is a part of the
investigation okay this is part of that
investigation Mike Pompeo said recently
like the level of inferred infiltration
of the China of Chinese intelligence and
like into the United States is crazy
it's just mean I see it I could I get
the feeling that the reason this is not
being blown up is because China has its
hands in the media also totally you know
like it's why why isn't this like
blasted everywhere like wait China's
trying to say we did this bioterrorist
attack and then here's proof that
they're actually been smuggling it into
our country like let's so let's read
another one on
anyway man on or about 26 May 28th Tina
Chinese national entered the United
States via D it's always from Detroit to
from Beijing Oh probably because they
fly straight over over the North Pole
the People's Republic of China when
stopped by CBP the individuals stated he
was a breast cancer researcher in Texas
and was not traveling with any
biological products the individual was
referred for additional CBP inspection
where he amended his declaration to
possibly traveling with plasmids CBP
discovered one centrifuge tube and the
individuals checked bag and he stated it
was non-infectious ecoli bacteria
derived plasmids the individual was
unable to provide any accompanying
documentation or permits for the
materials which see be placed on an
agricultural hold and the individual was
released why are they releasing these
people yeah I know you meant to declare
that you're bringing in that the SARS
virus and the fact that they're lying
about it it's like that no I don't have
anything okay well what's that vial oh I
done it I do have a SARS it's like
excuse me
no no it's are you sure we're gonna keep
it go ahead what they're saying is they
asked the guy are you traveling thing I
am NOT okay let searches back actually
oh you're searching my bag well it's
like I'm gonna amend that it's kind of
like they're there hoping they won't
search them so like nope we're good it's
like all right have a nice day sir
yeah and so then that sounds like all
right let's check whoa wait wait wait
yes I do have one they lied man yeah why
are these people being allowed in
exactly this is nuts why are you still
being allowed into the country you're
lying
check this part out the FBI does not
state precisely what sort of biosecurity
risk these cases could present but Raina
MacIntyre professor of global
biosecurity the University of New South
Wales in Sydney said the FBI appears to
be concerned with dual use of research
that that would be that would be used
for bioterrorism that could be would be
and if the illicit sample said in the
report were being brought into the u.s.
she says the traffic is likely to be
both ways here's a quote how do you know
what they're bringing in and out unless
you have a comprehensive surveillance
point chest if it's going one way it's
going the other way you'd be very naive
to assume otherwise yeah I agree
retired Air Force Brigadier General
Robert Spaulding who worked on China
issues on the Nationals
charity counsel under the Trump
administration said there is a threat
posed by Chinese nationals carrying
biological samples but believes it's
likely the carry the carrier would be
some someone who is unwitting making it
hard to determine the intent some likely
could be deliberate to test our ability
to identify and intercept others could
be opportunistic the FBI report refers
to both biosecurity which typically
refers to the intentional misuse of
pathogens such as bioterrorism and
biosafety which covers accidental
release the FBI declined to comment on
the report mom Yahoo straight-up just
said and got an expert to say that these
people are as a concern they're engaging
in bioterrorism yeah that the FBI is
digging into it
I'm not surprised the FBI's we're not
gonna comment because maybe this could
this this information getting out could
be a problem for their investigation
true but how long until the meet like
the so I expect this will get no play
it's not sensational it's not about the
orange man no one's gonna want to talk
about it actually more unless we
actually do go to war with China and
then this is gonna be front-page like we
actually did know that China has been
planning an attack
look see we have the proof our news
cycle is so twisted and stupid it's so
die great yeah I don't understand that
me like right yeah you know no one's
telling you anything it's important
that's gonna help save your life protect
your life but well that's why I was
saying like I think journalists don't
want to touch this because they want to
take the path of least resistance
yeah look man I just want a million
views can I just call Donald Trump
Hitler again do I really have to talk
about national security issues do I have
to like do footwork and talk to DOJ
people Oh open-source make phone calls
you nuts get out of here
I'll just write a lunch man bad again an
orange man was bad again today because
he is orange boom a million hits boom
yeah million bucks yeah and then
advertising revenue is dropping and
they're like we need a bailout from the
government they're getting it yes media
organizations can apply for up to a ten
million dollar loan if there was no
services man yep pretty ridiculous but
it depends on who gets it because if
it's like local news it's fine by not
essential no I mean local news I think
is okay and there's moves better I guess
let's be honest
they could've done a better job of this
I think they buried the lede but this is
journalism they contacted a retired
general to ask him what was going on
there cut they contacted an expert they
published these documents they did the
legwork they found some really damning
information yeah and this is very very
important information done by good
journalism it's huge yeah they could
done better I think but it's like you
know I'll give it a seven out of ten
like this is important stuff this is
still one of the craziest things about
coronavirus that I think that I've found
that they have been smuggling stuff it
to our country like how is that not a
war one upset yeah like I'm mad right
now
yes man you've gotten so Jesus angry how
dare you it is akin to an act of war
like how is it not there's nobody like
that we're starting it I know I don't
want to go to war either but when
they're bringing in this stuff to our
country it's like what's going on and
now we have 160,000 people infected with
one of these SARS viruses you know and
look even if it isn't bioterror it
related maybe it's just bumbling morons
so this this this story falls in line
with a bunch of other stories we've read
where they've been concerned that the
actually they bring it up to there's
international concern China won't do
like they won't actually care they'll be
they'll be negligent in containing this
you know biological materials so under
the assumption that they're doing
legitimate research they're not
containing these things properly yeah
and so that's the concern some some
[ __ ] has a vial of you know h1n1 and
he's on a plane in case and then he
trips and falls in a break thing you
look Josh yep I'm not saying you did I'm
saying that's the risk yeah and on an
airplane no less every cycle there yeah
or just you're in an airport and it
dudes walking around an infectious
disease no it's fine but the crazy thing
is there's multiple instances where
they're not reporting it so it's like we
kind of know what they're doing they're
lying man
yep yeah I don't know there's notes this
is this that what's crazy is I've had a
few people I mentioned this the other
day asking me if we if I thought we are
getting heading towards like a full-on
war with China mm-hmm you better believe
it yeah I think so this is you know I
don't know how you you rectify this
what's the what's the are
in here no no Tim your mistake and this
happens all the time they always try and
bring in vials of viruses in light of
this lesson the borders agent Porter
agents oh yeah okay well that needs to
stop
yeah actually we stopped that it reminds
me of that Family Guy episode where the
the bar burns dead like the Barbera a
new some guy buys the bar and then the
bar burns down insurance guy pays the
check and then they like everyone all
the wives ask him they're like don't you
find a little strange that the day after
he bought the insurance the bar burned
down he goes no it happens all the time
so it's like that's a funny point about
the bias in like no this stuff happens
all the time
yeah just because they're doing it a lot
yeah Wow well the good news is I get I
guess and I mean that very very
sarcastically is based on things like
this we could prepare for a hundred
thousand people to die oh great yeah you
know what though man we're like we were
we were initially thinking about leading
with like okay I guess doctor foul she
says I'm fast people gonna die I just
I'm so over it
thanks for checking out this clip from
the Tim cast IRL podcast we do the show
live Monday through Friday at 8 p.m. if
you want to catch the full show tune in
to this channel subscribe hit the like
button or check us out on iTunes and
Spotify and we will soon have this
podcast up for free on all podcast
platforms thanks for hanging out and
we'll see you all in the next episode
you